Hi, this is Dr. Cutters, and I'm going to talk to you about our live Q&A. We're just starting this
So you won't have a lot of videos to pull from. But as we go weekly
We're going to be recording these videos and you'll be able to access them
Bad time to make a video and my voice isn't so great today
But I wanted to get this information out to you. So our holistic health hour is something that we have done in the past where I did live videos and such
Well, this time we're going to open it up to everybody. We're trying to
To basically build a ministry that we can help people no matter what no matter what their financial situation
Maybe you just need a question quickly answered. Well, that's what this is for. Well, what is it?
Well, this is going to be a live
holistic health hour, a live Q&A or Dr. Cutters me. There's a picture of me
Intercede I stole this picture from a site that was trying to bash us
I love to
utilize things that try to undermine us because that shows the power of God and that's what we're trying to do in this
In this Q&A. I certainly don't know everything
But I'll promise you that I'll tell you if you ask a question and I don't know it
Or I'll figure it out. I'll try to find that answer for you as best I possibly can
So you can submit questions on our website
You can submit questions that I'll put in a little PowerPoint or I'll just try to go through them and answer those questions
So if you can't get on the live Q&A, they'll be recorded
So if you submit a question like I can't get on at two o'clock on central time
But if you submit a question, you can watch it. You can watch the video later and get your question answered
You can also ask questions live. So we're trying to
Just try to help people
I'm not perfect. I'll give you honest answers. You'll always know that for me
When is it? It's going to be every Wednesday at two o'clock central time
So you'll have to check your time how that fits into that and they'll ask anywhere from 15 minutes to 60 minutes or some days
I might go beyond that some days. I may cut that off
But you can jump on ask questions
And if you listen to other people's questions, you can learn a lot that might spark some questions you have on any health related topic
I'll gladly talk about and I'll give you the information that I've gained over the years
I've been out in practice since the late 80s
So I got a lot of information that I could
Glean from and I'll be honest. I'm not medical bashing
But I have an alternative minded practitioner from a Christian perspective
So if that's what you're looking for you can feel free to call it and ask me questions or jump on our zoom call you don't call it
Why? Well again, we're a ministry. We're trying to help people. We're always trying to figure out ways that we can help people better
That's why I created all our courses. That's something new in the last two years
I created all these courses and now they're offered at a severely discounted price
So that you can watch videos and learn about autoimmune disease about live disease about detoxification
And get real information instead of some of the kind of
Nonsense that you can get on Instagram and Facebook try to give you more information that comes from research
That isn't just you know radical alternative, but it's real research and real clinical data that I founded by practice of
Nearly 40 years so
Make sure you tune in and see if you like it
Where is it go to this page that you found this video or go to our my hope for line
Website or our colors clinic website and you'll see a link to our live Q&A that'll bring you to a page where it'll show you
The link to the zoom call
So once you get to the zoom call every Wednesday you could jump on and to a clock central time and you could watch the
The zoom call learn from other people's questions again or
Ask your questions line understand you have to agree to the disclaimer
We're not giving medical advice. It's not a substitute for your doctor and but it's information that then maybe you could take back to your doctor
We don't need to be a substitute for your practitioner
It's information you can bring back to your practitioner. Maybe ask them questions
And always if you need to make a personal appointment with me
You do so online you schedule online all our scheduling is self-scheduling though
So just complete the intake form and you can schedule online
But this is also for people who maybe don't want to go to that next step that want more information
We're trying to be that aid. We really believe in Hosea 46 where it says our people are
My people are destroyed for lack of knowledge now I understand
Scripturally the context that's talking about knowledge of God
But it's also of what God has created us to know so that we can be wise in our decision making for health care for diet for
Everything it's I believe that God is holistic. He cares about you and your body
And that's what we're trying to convey through this is just to give wise insight so you can make the best decisions for you and your family
I hope to see you there